sono un po triste perché oggi portiamo a
termine una delle serie che a katherine
ha caratterizzato in modo particolare al
mio canale è quindi diamoci la giusta
importanza a questo finale let's go my
brothers adocchiato le ultime cose che
devo fare quindi teoricamente deve
essere tutto in ordine
partiamo se c'è o che stanno andando
vediamo se riesco a rubarli brutto che
da questo vagone 4 dopo il carro armato
tra l'altro perché ce l'ho io da solo ti
fai che milani merda harry lo fa sono
entrato col calato dentro il treno che
stanno continuato a dare a manica
ma come fai a raggiungere addio
ho fatto giusto salve accorda marco
onofri rai
agi
be nice non male ma devo fare questo per
conto mio
adesso ha fermato il treno cacchio devo
arrivare alla stanza di pilotaggio vai
vai vai correre già fatto a chi tua
porta bene sono io a zio aringhe questa
signora ba miles davis
cos'è quella roba la giovane mago fa
come possibile l'hanno fatto uguale a
sex drive
[Musica]
la tua addio ai ragazzi un mare
bellissimo facciamo mercy arcavacata
e pazzesco fantasia cosidetta fa ho
colpito gli ha levato uno
e vabbè e come dischi
mamma mia che della dora mancava solo
hayden item mirror lo specchio soca
nobili e vorrei che durasse di più
vorrei che durasse di più è bellissimo è
stato veramente la figata uguale
benissimo e dei back
ciao è uscito dalla finestra
by the sea in flight ma ora psi ma non
certo adesso c'è c'è più vabbè ha
funzionato che tattica raga mamma mia è
effettivamente di shock complete ce l'ho
fatta ma che bello vaganova bella
insegnante atene è stata spettacolare ma
bellissima c'è questo qua
dalla musica antica nel caso il dia una
mano
fra gli scaricabarile bellissima
videogiochi e rischi ben garant e più
profondi
dalla musica capisce
come sarà lady
faceva
tanti canadesi infiltration
[Musica]
si no
i vendor
gli uffici dai centri stessi
le cose
è la madonna chip fighting combes ok
vai stato lo stesso attacco va bene ma
basta e morto bellissimo o carina no
accresciuto vuoi non cresci armi te
prego vagherà era figo finora quando
fate le robe abbastanza complesse mi
cresce al gioco non ho capito per far
venire
ciao ciao a questo mission completerà va
alla fine che lascia sempre quando
completa la missione l'abbiamo fatta
[Musica]
niente abbonamento ma che minchia adesso
non abbiamo fatto un casino avente siamo
andati let's golf masters bar di hunter
very nice
manca solo il rubino e il camion
mamma mia ragazzi è stata una cavalcata
incredibile ma questo è il finale dei
finali perché l'ultimo innesco quattro
ore prima del lancio va bene ok ok bye
bye bye bye michael cohl monopattino le
scott jump be nice
sweet rock prova vede stato un altro
stop e pengo di per passare a scelte
grazie ma cosa da fare qua bravissimo
il segmento e quindi mi ha lanciato il
guscio di vaio che prende il primo
mandato schiacciare la uno di allungare
qua trovate da smile erano volete
saperne aspetto li investo e fatti
magari per aspettare non si era infatti
così sia cambiato il cappello come tra
pranzi fratello di lei ma leggo togli lì
sono rimasti lì
ottima idea non si sono tolti questi
quadri come m la destra mischia
proiettili dentro ritirato dalla
macchina come stanno parlando c'è anche
un gallery damasco
non ho mai watch astratti rare
è preciso shop
spara la cavo bravo come il palloncino
l'ha fatta mi sciolgo plate l'ex velina
choir leader
[Musica]
brutta forma è stata una bellissima
cavalcata è stato bellissimo e mi
dispiace perché spero che ne facciano
altri perché è troppo è veramente troppo
bello quindi spero facciano un altro
episodio di sicuro grazie aver seguito
la serie sul canale grazie mille spero
vi sia piaciuta lasciato come sonia
miliardi di rischio
[Musica]
bella ragazza
no
[Musica]